[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen in sallys welt heute
gibt es ein weiteres ramadan das rezept
für euch und zwar hat sich eine freundin
von mir dass er ihn schon immer mal
cannoli gewünscht das ist ein
italienisches rezept wenn ich heute
nicht machen aber ich mache heute ein
zusammenspiel aus cannoli und dem
türkischen kniffe kinder erkennt ihr
dass es ein dessert aus also mit diesem
engelshaar hier engelshaar und käse
richtig lecker solltet ihr unbedingt mal
ausprobieren
es klingt komisch aber schmeckt wirklich
supergut kaffee ist es jetzt aber nicht
diese teig fäden die heißen kdf die gibt
es glaube ich auch bei jedem türkischen
supermarkt und auch mittlerweile schon
in großen deutschen supermärkten sag ich
jetzt mal und dieses engels hat kann man
auch selber machen aber es ist natürlich
ziemlich aufwendig weil die wirklich
sehr sehr dünn sind
ich benutze das jetzt hier und werde
kleine hörnchen formen die dann aussehen
wie cannoli und daneben auch gefüllt
werden ich bereite jetzt hier erstmal
das engelshaar vor und zwar zog der das
ganz vorsichtig auseinander
und ich habe hier auch schon mal ein
bisschen butter auf dem herzen schmelzen
das brauche ich nämlich auch gleich ich
ziehe die teig strenge ganz vorsichtig
auseinander ohne sie zu sehr auseinander
zu reißen
bei kinder verwenden sehr wirklich ganz
klein gerissen aber ich möchte sie jetzt
gleich wickeln daher wirklich so lange
wie möglich lassen aber trotzdem diese
dicken klumpen hindemith schon entfernt
[Musik]
diese type fäden die sind schon etwas zu
feiern die schmeiß ich aber nicht weg
darauf lässt sich nicht kirre machen
kann ich jetzt ganz gut einfrieren und
dann wenn ich es zubereiten möchte
einfach auftauchen
ich nehme jetzt hier eine höhere form
wenn ihr die nicht habt könnt ihr auch
alle folie zu recht formeln oder was ich
auch besser finde ihr könnt auch ein
muffin form nehmen und einfach so kleine
cups machen statt diese hörnchen
alufolie findet immer nicht ganz so
nachhaltig oder eben diese hörnchen
formen da gibt es auch ganz viele tolle
rezepte wenn ihr wollt mache ich auch
gerne mehr rezepte dafür jetzt nehmt ihr
einfach die butter bestreicht die form
damit jetzt einen langen tag streifen
nehmen den ersten hier unten so ein
bisschen befestigen und dann von oben
nach unten schön dicht auf rollen und
dann gerne einfach den nächsten nehmen
noch mal dran setzen und so dicht wie
möglich auf rollen
[Musik]
anschließend dann mit der butter
bestreichen die gibt dem ganzen noch mal
ein bisschen form und natürlich auch
geschmack
[Musik]
einfacher geht es wenn ihr sie vorher
ein bisschen 'schon gebuttert sodann
kleben sie schon mal schön zusammen
[Musik]
jetzt sind knifflig aber wichtig ist
eigentlich nur dass wir richtig liegen
durchs backen werden sie dann wirklich
schön fest
[Musik]
es ist ziemlich knifflig aber es geht
jetzt hier nochmal schön mit butter
bestreichen und sobald sich die teilten
die folge sagt haben mit der butter
lassen sie sich auch besser formen also
dann drücke ich sie noch mal an dem
hörnchen schön fest
[Musik]
die überschüssige butter die läuft dann
sowieso raus
[Musik]
ich war jetzt kurz meine hände und steht
die schon mal in den backofen so dass
wir wirklich schön goldbraunen geröstet
werden und kann in der zwischenzeit auch
schon mal den zuckersirup machen
[Musik]
für den zuckersirup verwende ich 150
gramm zucker 75 gramm wasser einen
spritzer zitronensaft und ein teelöffel
rosenwasser und gibt jetzt einfach alle
zutaten in den topf also erst zucker und
wasser lasse ich jetzt aufkochen und den
zuckersirup bereitet man immer so zu
dass der einfach schön abkühlen kann
deswegen mache ich denn jetzt direkt
[Musik]
jetzt kocht oder sirup da gebe ich jetzt
einem spritzer zitronensaft dazu meine
mama sagt er immer hat damit der zucker
sirup einfach nicht so kristallisiert
und für den geschmack ein bisschen
rosenwasser er plötzlich ihn einfach nur
23 minuten köcheln bis er am faden
herunter läuft also erzählte gerade da
fließt noch nicht so schön aber wenn ich
jetzt 23 minuten kochen lassen fließt es
gleich wie ein faden
[Musik]
den sirup lasse ich jetzt abkühlen und
kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
zitronencreme zu bereiten für die
zitronencreme verwende ich 50 gramm
zitronensaft 70 gramm zucker 250 gramm
aus capone etwas vanille extrakt 300
gramm sahne und salat
die mascarpone ihr könnt aber auch
frischkäse nehmen kurz verrühren
dann bruder zucker dazu ihr könnt auch
stadt zitronensaft butter zucker
einrühren
das habe ich meist immer im kühlschrank
das geht auch dann langsam die sahne
dazugeben mit zitronensaft verfeinern
mangel extrakt nicht vergessen und mit
seiner fahrt steif schlagen
[Musik]
jetzt einfach die creme in einem
spritzbeutel füllen mit einer stelle zb
hier sitzen spritzbeutel echt
empfehlenswert denn die hörnchen lassen
sich ansonsten wirklich sehr schwer
füllen weil es einfach so spitz so lang
sind
jetzt nehme ich die abgekühlten hörnchen
ganz vorsichtig 70 schon mal auf meinen
servierteller sind vorsichtig das
hörnchen rausziehen jetzt mit hilfe des
spritzbeutel ganz vorsichtig die creme
ein film erst mal hinten ausstopfen und
dann ruhig nach vorne bisschen
verlängern
es ist nämlich noch frische erdbeeren
dazu
[Musik]
hier lege ich jetzt einfach noch vor dem
fernseher gefächerte erdbeeren hin dann
gehackten pistazien noch drüber das
sieht immer gut aus und schmeckt vor
allem sehr gut und wenn ihr möchtet noch
gerne den sirup drüber laufen lassen
ein bisschen davon dann war ich der kdf
noch ein bisschen auf aber zu viel gebe
ich jetzt auch nicht raus
[Musik]
ich glaube jetzt hoffe ich den mut auch
mal probieren
[Musik]
nochmals probieren ja ja das ist das
dessert
man muss sagen von allen rezepten die
ich jetzt gemacht habe ist das ein
bisschen das kniffligste weil man
wirklich dieses engelshaar dekade um
diese form wickeln mussten aber ich
finde dafür sieht echt extrem gut aus
gehört es sieht aus wie so einen coolen
restaurant kennt ihr vielleicht kennt
während sich aus dem motto das ist so
eine typische restaurantkette der türkei
die machen so spezialität ist es richtig
cool aus und ich denke das gedacht hatte
ich einfach die creme nicht so sehr ist
super nicht zu süß und einem türkischen
meisters nicht wenn es irgendwie zu süß
ist und deswegen habe ich jetzt auch den
zuckersirup bosch wird richtig gut
den zuckersirup nutzen schluss ein
bisschen obendrauf damit es nicht zu süß
wird weil ich finde auch die dsf immer
zu sehen ist geld das ich immerzu
folglich probieren wie das kloster will
ich wollte mich dass das gleich zerstört
bewegen wie bei unserer hochzeit habe
ich dich auch gefüttert
er frisst mehr ausbildung hammer hammer
ist gut nicht so ganz leicht super
wirklich und ich glaub mir den frischen
erdbeeren weil jetzt im ramadan auch
erdbeerzeit gerade ist das ist gut weil
dann hat man etwas schönes frisches und
ich würde euch da vorschlagen darf ruhig
mal kam wagen einfach nur hammer
wirklich wo ich liebte es wahnsinn
und im prinzip könnt ihr die hörnchen
vorbereiten ihr könnt die sahne
vorbereiten und in den kühlschrank
stellen
und dann der sirup leise auch schon
bereit das heißt einfach kurz vor dem
verzehr alles zusammenfügen gewärtig und
wenn ihr übrigens kleine hörnchen wollt
dann könnt ihr so wie hier einfach nur
die hälfte auf rollen dann sind es
kleinere portionen oder wie gesagt
enough in form einfach rein drücken eine
mulde in der mitte man könnte das auch
wieso kleine martin kaps machen ja aber
sofern nicht die form eigentlich so
macht es nach geschmeckt so lecker
wahrscheinlich passten gerade
wahrscheinlich ja
wer mag vorgedreht ja wir haben vor
gedreht und zwar ich heute januar
nein und ich bin so braun weil ich
wollte auch gewalt ist so braun
jaja meine gattin habe einen verbleib
aber die ist ganz logisch ich mache das
nach muss sich beeilen ernährungsform
ich muss zum elterngespräch in den
kindergarten villa ja ja
entlang der spree invictus gespräche
falls ihr das rezept nach macht dann
schaut einfach stecke den kopf um die
kamera angestoßen
achso durch genießt weil hier das rezept
machen wollt findet ihr es auch sallys -
blog.de ich wünsche euch noch einen
wunderschönen ramadan
ich hoffe dass meine dass er bei euch
auf dem tisch landet ob jetzt gerne mal
ausschreibt mir einen kommentar und
macht auch gerne ein foto und ladedruck
damit ich denke bis zum nächsten mal
damit machen die sucht kann schulbesuch
mal ja
[Musik]